estamos en la parte de la región r se
rota alrededor del eje x para formar un
sólido encuentre el volumen del sólido
en términos de k si es que éste es
nuestra región r y esta va a rotar
alrededor del eje x para formar un
sólido y este sólido se verá algo así
en esta parte de aquí es estas son aquí
que estamos rotando se va a ver así y
luego
estoy dibujando lo mejor
puedo
esto se va a ver de la siguiente manera
esta es la forma aproximada que tiene
ese sólido parecido a una bocina puedes
imaginar que aquí tenemos el eje y esta
línea vertical es el eje y y por el
centro del sólido por el centro del
sólido estaría pasando el eje x y xi el
sólido quizás fuera transparente se
vería el otro lado y el eje x se vería
atravesando el centro del sólido como
encontramos el volumen de este sólido
podemos pensar en cada uno de los
distintos discos que constituyen este
sólido cómo le hacemos tomemos uno de
estos discos puedes imaginarte que es
una sección transversal de este sólido
de tal manera que este disco va a tener
una área en la base una cara y una
cierta profundidad puedes imaginarte que
es como una moneda donde esa profundidad
va a ser la orilla de la moneda y el
área de la base corresponde al área de
la cara de la moneda cuál va a ser el
volumen entonces de este disco
que tenemos aquí va a ser el área de la
base por la profundidad y cuál es el
área de la base el área de la base será
de un círculo que es por radio al
cuadrado entonces el área la base va a
ser igual aquí
por el radio al cuadrado y cuál es este
radio el radio es la altura que va desde
el eje x hasta la función la función es
a la 2x entonces el área de uno de estos
discos ubicado en la posición x va a ser
igual a pi por ea la 2 x elevado al
cuadrado y cuál va a ser el volumen de
ese disco el volumen de ese disco es el
área de la base que es y por el lado
sexy al cuadrado por el espesor que es
de x
es el volumen de este disco que tenemos
aquí que tiene un espesor infinitamente
pequeño
lo que queremos hacer es sumar todos
estos discos aquí tenemos un montón de
sus discos de esos discos infinitamente
pequeños queremos tomar una suma
infinita de esos infinitamente delgados
discos es decir queremos sumar sumar
desde x igual a cero hasta x igual acá
aquí tenemos x igual acá aquí tenemos x
igual a 0 y sumamos todos los discos
para obtener el volumen total podemos
evaluar esta integral no está tan
difícil déjame escribirla aquí abajo
aquí tenemos a la 2 x elevado al
cuadrado es a la 4 x 2 x x 2 es 4x
podemos obtener esta integral por
inspección pero también puedes decir
mira aquí tienes 4x necesitamos su
derivada la diva de 4x es igual a 4 y
vamos a dividir entre 4 para que no se
altere el expresión si multiplicas por 4
y divides entre 4 estas multiplicando
por 1 entonces no salte a la expresión
lo que esto hace y déjame describir esto
entonces tenemos entre 4 x 4
a la 4x hemos multiplicado por cuatro y
entre cuatro ana lemos alterado
lo que hemos hecho aquí es sacar la
derivada de 4x que es 4
entonces esto esta expresión la podemos
reescribir de la siguiente manera y
sobre 4 que es una constante y sale
fuera la integral y sobre 4 la integral
de 0 acá de 4 y a la 4 x de x y la razón
por la que he hecho esto es porque aquí
tenemos esta expresión y aquí está su
derivada entonces hemos completado esta
expresión podríamos pensar que esto es a
la equis que estamos integrando a la
equis o más bien podríamos decir que
estamos integrando con respecto a 4x de
tal manera que esta integral sería la 4x
y lo puede checar si tú derivas a la 4x
vas a tener 4 a la 4 x
entonces esta expresión es la anti
derivada de estar acá y la vamos a
evaluar entre 0 y k multiplicada por pi
cuartos
todo x inti cuartos entonces
evaluamos entonces encaja evaluando en k
esto resulta que a la 4 acá tenemos así
y cuartos por el a 4 k menos a la 4 por
0 es el acero que es igual a 1
aquí tenemos entonces nuestro volumen pi
cuartos por ea la 4 k menos 1 y hemos
concluido así la parte d ya hicimos
parte de íbamos a ser la parte c el
volumen b encontrado en la parte de
cambia a medida que cambia si decaen dt
la derivada de k con respecto a t es
igual un tercio de termina de vender la
divida debe con respecto a t cuando acá
es igual a un medio esto se puede
resolver directamente a partir de la
regla de la cadena y si tú contempla los
diferenciales como números muy pequeños
lo cual es parte del sentido común la
tasa de cambio debe o un cambio muy
pequeño en b con respecto a un cambio
muy pequeño en t es igual a un cambio
muy pequeño en b con respecto un cambio
muy pequeño en k x un cambio muy pequeño
en k con respecto a un cambio muy
pequeño en t
o la derivada de b con respecto a t es
igual la deriva de b con respecto a k
por la derivada de k con respecto a t y
la razón por la que dije que esto hacía
sentido si tú veías un diferencial como
número pequeño y esto que te voy a
mostrar no es un tratamiento riguroso
tiene que ver más con aplicar un buen
sentido común es decir si tus o pones
que son números estos términos se pueden
cancelar y tendrías dv en dt a ambos
lados de la igualdad por eso he dicho
que usando un poco el sentido común lo
puedes ver hacia esta expresión nos da
esencialmente lo que queremos obtener
buscamos de vendetta nos dan decaen dt
que es igual a un tercio cuando k es
igual a un medio así es que nos están
dando nos están dando la tasa de cambio
de k con respecto a t sabemos que esto
de aquí es igual a un tercio y podemos
calcular la iba de ver con respecto a
acá fácilmente pues tenemos b como
función de k en esta expresión hagamos
eso
entonces la derivada de b con respecto a
k
es igual a cuartos
por la derivada de esto que es la ira de
alá 4k -1 la deriva de menos un el ayuda
de una constante que es igual a cero en
tres serían a más la derivada de la 4k
que es 4 a la 4 k
estos chicos se cancelan y nos da y por
ea la 4 k la cual es la derivada de b
con respecto a k nos piden que
determinemos esta derivada cuando acá es
igual un medio entonces p prima en un
medio o más bien podemos poner debe en
década cuando acá es igual un medio es
igual a pi por a la 4 por un medio lo
cual es igual a pi por ea la 2
entonces aquí tenemos deben de acá que
hemos calculado que es igual a ti porque
al cuadrado traslativa debe con respecto
a t
cuando caes igual un medio y deben de t
perdón cuando acá es igual a un medio y
la derivada de k con respecto a t es
igual un tercio deben de te va a ser
igual a pie cuadrada por un tercio
déjame describirlo por acá db en de te
va a ser igual a pie cuadrado por un
tercio que es cuadrada sobre 3
hemos terminado